[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans I'm
Sean Evans and this is our hot one
season ten hot sauce reveal and what a
momentous day it is you know when I
think back on the early days of Tony
Yayo in Texas Pete's all the way through
season nine Stone Cold Steve Austin and
pucker butts chocolate plague whoever
thought a YouTube chicken wing talk show
could take it this far
and here in our very special season 10
it's all about saying thank you so much
to the fans who rocked with us through
nine seasons and of course thank you as
well to some of our favorite hot sauce
makers in the game for season 10 it's
hot ones all-star edition we asked some
of our favorite producers in show
history to make a brand new sauce and
bring it to the table for this historic
season in each sauce curated
specifically for the wings of death I'm
excited are you excited I'm excited are
you excited I'm excited are you excited
kicking things off in the leadoff spot
you know what time it is the classic
welcomes guests to the table with a warm
from the handshake of chile de árbol it
says hi nice to meet you celebrity I've
never met before you can trust me all
right in the number two spot our friends
at small acts peppers have whipped up a
Chicago red jalapeno sauce that was
inspired by me the subtly sweet blend of
jalapenos mustard and celery salt make
this hot sauce the equivalent of
dragging your hot dog through the garden
and putting some wheels on it and
speaking of Gardens the peppers are
grown in community gardens in my
hometown thank you so much small acts
peppers a ray of sunshine in this dark
dark cold world the doom but doom but
doom
what's that what's that you hear yeah
that's right heart beat hot sauce is
back baby this time they're bringing
some tropical vibes down from the great
white north with a pineapple habanero
number made with beaver duck session IPA
from sleeping giant brewery and Thunder
Bay Ontario squeeze it on a slice of
Hawaiian pizza if you're into that
a thing and oh my gosh what is this
los calientes at number 4 but Shawn that
must mean the entire lineup is hotter
than ever nice detective work you
Scoville Sherlock's its season 10 no one
is safe but don't worry explain that
Graham it has a new comrade-in-arms in
the five spot in the form of headless
horseradish from our friends at torch
bearer sauces in central pennsylvania
horseradish and a hot sauce is every bit
as mind-blowing and practice as it
sounds on paper especially with a kiss
of smoky Chipotle to balance out the
bite mmm and at number six its fiyah
fiyah no seriously that's the name of
the sauce fire fire from Hawaii's own
adobo loco jalapeno check scorpion check
smoked ghost peppers check the chili
bonanza ensures that the fire hits every
part of the mouth to kick off the back
half and then moving on it's bravado
spice company's acha me so this is the
first red miso hot sauce to hit the
market earthy savory flavors of miso and
sesame they combined with Reapers and
ghost peppers to say konichiwa to anyone
who's still yet to feel the heat this
deep in the lineup and then at the
eighth spot that's right
des bomb is back fights have broken out
at hot ones headquarters about replacing
the bomb I've said it before I'll say it
again from my cold dead hands
you hear that Sarah Honda you hear that
Chris Schoenberger des bomb it stays
show some respect
and speaking of respect at the nine spot
karma sauce is cranking out its hottest
sauce to date just for hot ones it's
called
burn after eating it's a pun that's sure
to inspire its fair share of butt hole
gags but the ingredients are no laughing
matter
the fiery Indian inspired flavors are
accented with caraway and I'm sure an
ingredient that comes from green unripe
mangoes and then here at the 10 spot I
know you've been eyeing it it's gold
shimmering like the wrist [ __ ]
it's a pun that's sure to inspire its
fair share of butthole gags but the
ingredients are no laughing matter
the fiery Indian inspired flavors are
accented by caraway and I'm sure an
ingredient that comes from green unripe
mangoes and then at the number 10 spot
I know you've been eyeing it I've been
eyeing it too you see the drip the gold
it is the last dab xxx that's triple the
heat with three distinct varieties of
pepper X chocolate X peach X and mustard
X but before we start feeding the last
dab xxx to our celebrity guinea pigs we
need to try it out on a civilian to make
sure that it does not actually kill
someone so without further ado it is
time to toss it to our royal taster hear
ye hear ye spice Lords tis I
King Bill the royal taster don't call me
a civilian Shaun today I'm gonna be the
first of many illustrious guests on hot
ones to taste the pain but first I'll
need my Lay's potato chip the perfect
vehicle for one's hot sauce needs but
how about a little warm-up chip
[Music]
classic and delicious let's crank it up
a bit with a nice healthy dab oh yes
let's give this a try yeah this is a
winning combination Wow it just hurts
you swallow it and it hurts milk please
servants man thank you Shawn get that
bag bill well there you have it it's our
season 10 line up welcome back to the
table some of our favorite makers and
hot ones history and we'll be putting
the gauntlet to the test next week
that's right hot ones returns at 11 a.m.
Eastern Time
next Thursday on first we feast thank
you so much to the fans who've rocked
with us through nine seasons strong and
into our historic 10th season
I can't wait can you we'll see you next
week baby
[Music]
take one okay
breaking news hot ones fans this is Sean
Evans checking in to say there's a major
storm a-brewin make sure that you batten
down the hatches
stock up on non perishables and while
you wait out the storm
why not binge watch some old hot ones
like comment subscribe who appreciates
you me